what I would suggest for people that
that experience moderate seasonal
depression would be to really emphasize
trying to get as much bright light in
your eyes as you can outside and if
appropriate exposing as much of your
bodily surface to light actually can be
useful too the dopamine system it does
many things in the body responsible for
movement motivation craving Etc but
dopamine is very strongly regulated by
seasonality the Melatonin signal does a
number of things it makes you sleepy Etc
it's going to make you feel a little bit
more subdued but it has a number of
Downstream effects as well human are
subject to subtle mood-based variations
and Physiology shifts across the year
and the reason is the following when
days are long because light inhibits
melatonin the duration of your melatonin
pulse as we call it is very short when
days are short and nights are very long
there's less light to inhibit melatonin
and so there's a long melatonin signal